REALLY A DRAMATIC SIGHT TO SEE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>>> MARK HURTLING, GENERAL,
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
YOUR REACTION TO THIS NEW
INFORMATION COMING IN TO CNN, A
SENIOR UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL SAYS
THE ENTIRE KYIV REGION HAS BEEN
LIBERATED.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE IN
STORE FOR THE UKRAINIANS NEXT.
BUT AN ENCOURAGING SIGN.
>> IT IS, JIM.
I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON ED'S
COMMENTARY A MINUTE AGO WHERE HE
SAID ALL WESTERN OFFICIALS
THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO BE AN
EASY RUSSIAN VICTORY.
I'LL REMIND YOU, I MENTIONED TO
YOU ABOUT 3 1/2 WEEKS AGO THIS
WAS NOT GOING TO BE HARD FOR THE
UKRAINIANS TO PUSH OFF THE
RUSSIAN ATTEMPTS AT OCCUPATION.
THE ONLY THING I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT WAS THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
EULLS OF ARTILLERY AND
LONG-RANGE MISSILES AGAINST
KYIV.
THEY HAD BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
PUSHING THOSE FORCES BACK.
THEY ARE CERTAINLY NOT
WITHDRAWING ACROSS THE BOARD.
THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO
REPOSITION, TO LOOK FOR NEW
ORDERS.
I THINK THE NEXT STEP WILL BE
HOW DOES THE RUSSIAN FORCE
REGENERATE ITSELF?
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
DIFFERENT AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
NORTH OF KYIV, THE EAST OF KYIV,
AND NEAR CHERNIHIV, IS THAT THE
RUSSIANS FORCES HAVE SUSTAINED
SUBSTANTIAL LOSSES IN BOTH
EQUIPMENT AND MANPOWER.
YOU KNOW, THE DEATHS, AS I'VE
BEEN SAYING FOR SO LONG, WILL BE
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
PREDICTIONS.
WE'RE SEEING THAT BY THE FACT
THERE ARE UNFORTUNATELY DEAD
RUSSIAN BODIES EVERYWHERE.
SO I THINK THE COMBINATION OF
THE UNBELIEVABLE ASSAULT BY
UKRAINIAN FORCES IN THEIR
DEFENSIVE OPERATIONS AND HAVING
LIMITED ASSAULTS, THE LACK OF
TRAINING AGAIN BY THE RUSSIAN
FORCES.
AND WE CAN SEE IT IN THAT
DEMONSTRATION.
IF YOU'RE SENDING A FORCE IN TO
TRY AND PACIFY THE LOCAL
CIVILIAN, YOU DON'T DO THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT THOSE FORCES WERE
DOING AGAINST A CIVILIAN
ACTIVITY THAT'S PROTESTING.
SO IN EVERY STEP OF THE WAY,
WE'VE SEEN A LACK OF TRAINING, A
LACK OF LEADERSHIP, A LACK OF
SUPPORT, AND AN EXTENSIVE AMOUNT
OF CASUALTIES ON THE RUSSIAN
SIDE.
>> IT IS ASTONISHING TO SEE IN
PART, GENERAL, BECAUSE WE DON'T
GET MANY GLIMPSES LIKE THIS INTO
WHAT IS HAPPENING INSIDE THE
UKRAINIAN RESISTANCE.
BUT THIS TAKES YOU RIGHT INTO
THE HEART OF IT.
THEY ARE STANDING UP TO THESE
RUSSIAN FORCES.
YES, THEY'RE RUNNING WHEN THERE
ARE EXPLOSIONS AND GUNFIRE, BUT
HERE WE ARE FOUR WEEKS INTO THIS
INVASION OF UKRAINE AND THE
UKRAINIANS ARE NOT GIVING UP.
THEY ARE RESISTING EVERYWHERE,
AND THINK OAR JUST TOUGH AS
NAILS.
>> THEY ARE, JIM.
WHAT I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
RIGHT NOW IS WE'VE SEEN THE
MULTIPLE WAR CRIMES OF RUSSIAN
FORCES SHELLING, CONDUCTING
MISSILE ATTACKS, BOMBING WITH
DUMB BOMBS CIVILIANS'
APARTMENTS, CIVILIAN TOWNS.
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT.
AS WE SEE THE FORCES, THE
RUSSIAN FORCES DRAW BACK FROM
KYIV, I'M GOING TO PREDICT THAT
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO SEE
INDICATORS OF MANY MORE WAR
CRIMES, NOT JUST AGAINST
CIVILIANS BUT AGAINST THE
MILITARY.
WE'LL SEE INDICATORS OF THAT I
THINK PROBABLY NEXT WEEK AS MORE
AND MORE JOURNALISTS GET INTO
THE AREA, BOTH, YOU KNOW,
"NATIONAL JOURNAL"ISTS,
INTERNATIONAL JOURNALISTS, AND
ESPECIALLY JOURNALISTS FROM
UKRAINE GET INTO THOSE AREAS
THEY KNEW SO WELL BEFORE THIS
ATTACK.
UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE AND MORE
INDICATORS OF UNTRAINED RUSSIAN
FORCES COMMITTING WAR CRIMES.
>> TODAY WE'RE LEARNING THE U.S.
IS EXPECTED TO FACILITATE THE
TRANSFER OF SOVIET-ERA TANKS TO
UKRAINE.
HELP US WITH THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THAT.
>> IT'S A BIG DEAL, JIM, BECAUSE
MANY PEOPLE DON'T KNOW, BUT
DURING THE SOVIET DAYS UKRAINE
ACTUALLY USED TO BUILD TANKS IN
UKRAINIAN LAND SPACE FOR THE
SOVIET UNION.
SO THEY KNOW HOW TO USE THESE
KIND OF TANKS, THE T-72s.
IT IS CERTAINLY A CHEAPER MODEL
THAN THE ABRAMS, BUT IT HAS THE
CAPABILITY THAT I THINK THE
UKRAINIANS NEED.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ABRAMS TANK, THE U.S.
STALWART TANK THAT I LOVE, THAT
I'VE SPENT MY CAREER ON, IT
COSTS ANYWHERE FROM DEPENDING ON
THE VARIANTS BETWEEN $2.5
MILLION TO $6 MILLION PER COPY.
IT HAS A TURBINE ENGINE.
IT HAS TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED
FIRE CONTROL SYSTEMS INSIDE THE
TURRET.
THE RUSSIAN TANK DOES NOT HAVE
THAT.
IN FACT, IT IS A 1960 CHEVROLET
COMPARED TO A FERRARI, IF YOU
WILL.
IT IS EASY TO MANIPULATE, EASY
TO USE, IT'S LIGHTER, IT HAS A
GUN CONTROL SYSTEM, AND THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES KNOW HOW TO USE
THEM BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD THEM
BEFORE.
SO THE TRANSFER FROM SOME OF THE
NATO NATIONS I'M ASSUMING
PROBABLY THE CZECH REPUBLIC AND
SLOVAKIA, WOULD BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT JUST TO GIVE MORE FIRE
POWER TO THE UKRAINIAN FORCE AS
THEY LOOK TO PERHAPS SHIFT THEIR
ATTENTION TOWARD THE EAST IN THE
DONBAS AND MAYBE EVEN A LITTLE
BIT TO THE NORTHEAST AND THE
SOUTHEAST AS WELL.
>> THIS WEEK THE PENTAGON SAID
THAT THE U.S. IS CONFIDENT THAT
PUTIN HAS BEEN MISINFORMED BY
HIS OWN ADVISERS ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE, THESE FAILURES THAT
HAVE BEEN DEMONSTRATED IN REPORT
AFTER REPORT.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS WITH COLONEL LATON,
GENERAL ZWACK EARLIER IN THE
PROGRAM, AND IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS SEEING THESE
LIES BOOMERANG BACK ON THEM.
THEY LIED ON THEIR WAY INTO
UKRAINE.
THEIR SOLDIERS WERE MISINFORMED,
MISLED AS TO WHAT THEY WERE
FIGHTING FOR.
AND NOW IT SEEMS, ACCORDING TO
U.S. OFFICIALS, BRITISH
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS, PUTIN IS
NOT GETTING ACCURATE INFORMATION
AS TO WHAT IS HAPPENING.
IT JUST SEEMS AS THOUGH PUTIN IS
KIND OF DROWNING IN HIS OWN
PROPAGANDA, IN HIS OWN LIES.
>> YEAH, I THINK SO, JIM.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A DEFINITION
FOR THE TERM TOXIC LEADERSHIP,
WHICH I WON'T GO INTO, BUT
CERTAINLY PUTIN EXHIBITS EVERY
QUALITY OF THAT.
WE CAN RECALL BACK A COUPLE OF
DAYS BEFORE THE ATTACK STARTED,
BEFORE THEY INVADED, THAT HE WAS
HAVING THE MEETING WITH ALL OF
HIS MINISTERS WHERE IT APPEARED
LIKE A COUPLE OF THE MINISTERS
WERE ATTEMPTING TO TALK TRUTH TO
POWER AND THEY WERE IMMEDIATELY
SHUT DOWN AND, IN FACT,
EMBARRASSED BY MR. PUTIN.
YOU KNOW, HE SAYS HE CAN
WITHSTAND THE SANCTIONS AND
CONTINUE ON ALTHOUGH THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE ARE BEARING THE BRUNT OF
THAT, BUT UNFORTUNATELY, WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE SOON IS I
THINK THE MOTHERS OF RUSSIA WILL
START STANDING UP BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, THE AMOUNT OF DEATHS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED, THE AMOUNT OF
CASUALTIES THAT THE RUSSIAN
FORCE HAS TAKEN CAN'T BE HIDDEN.
AND YOU'VE GOT THIS NEW
CONSCRIPTION THAT STARTED
YESTERDAY, ABOUT 130,000 RUSSIAN
TROOPS WILL START COMING INTO
THE FORCE BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE,
AND AT THE SAME TIME THE OLD
CONSCRIPTS, THE ONES WHO HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING THIS WAR, WILL
START TO WANT TO GO HOME.
WILL THEY BE STOPPED FROM DOING
SO TO CONTINUE THIS FIGHT?
WILL THEY BE RELEASED?
THE FAMILIES OF PARENTS --
EXCUSE ME, THE PARENTS OF
SOLDIERS, WHEN THEY START SEEING
THESE KIND OF THINGS, REALLY
HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF TROUBLE EVEN
IN SOCIETY LIKE RUSSIA.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE A SOCIETAL
BLOWBACK.
WE'VE SEEN THE BEGINNINGS OF IT
WITH PROTESTS IN KEY RUSSIAN
CITIES, BUT I BELIEVE THERE
ALREADY MORE AND MORE DUE TO THE
SANCTIONS, A LACK OF FOOD ON THE
SHELVES, AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
SOLDIERS THAT WON'T BE COMING
HOME FROM THE RUSSIAN FORCE.
>> YEAH.
WE WERE SHOWING THAT VIDEO
EARLIER ON IN THE PROGRAM OF
RUSSIANS SCRAMBLING FOR, YOU